yo welcome back to the edge with your
boy michah Parsons a hot and spicy bi
week by week went well everything went
well feel good ready to go into this big
Rams week you know we're gonna get into
it later um obviously I know we got a
buy so ask your questions about the
games this week in the chat and I answer
them so let's get right into it uh dog
of the week always like to stay positive
always like to stay in it and you
already know my dog of the week on
offense we got two people this week we
had to go two because how dominant these
guys were and my first dog of the week
is Lamar Jackson Action Jackson proving
why he got that Mega contract and why he
should have Ben got that Megan contract
I mean 21 for 27 393 total yards four
total touchdowns Unstoppable um that's a
way to bounce back that's a way to
bounce back uh proving the doub is wrong
uh rough loss last week uh people threw
some shade on them but that's how you
kind of bounce back show people why you
are who you are and I always love to see
that um let's listen to Lamar after his
performance we doing we supposed what we
supposed to do like I always said the
limit for us and we just showed a
glimpse today I believe Lamar you don't
seem very happy after performance like
this I mean I believe when you playing
regular season games you should be okay
you know with winning I'm all right with
winning but still regular season you
know and we made shs for improvement
from last week and early on in the
season I believe we did but just one
regular season game that's why I'm not
you know pleased with the win because we
was trying to strive for every job we
going to score put points on the board
but we didn't because of that fumble but
it's pretty good we got the win so I'm
satisfied when we doing we were supposed
to hey and I respect that 100% listen
guys when you trying to win a
championship and you're trying to go
places that other people aren't this is
all part about the journey right now
people talk about the journey talk about
this week that week and they look ahead
you just want to keep one foot in in
front of the other and talk about the
journey and where you're going where you
want to go yes that was a great win by
the Ravens but yes they have so much
more to do have so much more
accomplished keep polishing keep getting
better and that's what it's all about
and that's what you want to see out of
your leader your quarterback Lamar is
still hungry for more and that's what
you love to see so Rams Fans Ravens fans
y'all know what it is y' got a lucky one
um and continue have the success and he
shut some he opened some doors and you
know he did some things that not many
people thought he could do against that
Lions defense a team that was trying to
go five wins in a row since back in the
19 uh you know far 20 plus years ago so
he did that against the Lions defense
what can you say what happened to the
Lions defense well you could say they
went against Lamar Jackson you look at
around the league guys like Lamar guys
like Patrick Mahomes guys like Josh
Allen when they come into them big games
them big opportunities they just show up
and that's what you expect out of your
franchise quarterback to show up and
when you show up those are the results
their capabilities are well beyond other
quarterbacks in the league uh those
athletic tough quarterbacks that can get
outside the pocket extend plays use
their legs they're always hard to guard
so that's what makes it tough nothing
happens to the Lions defense Lions still
have a great team they still are
well-rounded playing great ball but they
went against a guy who's a top guy they
went to a tier guy and that's what you
expect out of your tier guy so nothing
happened the Rams I mean the uh Lions
will continue to keep bouncing back but
you know they're going to keep getting
better but they went against a head
honcho and they just got bit you know
and it happens that's the nature of
football Any Given Sunday you truly
never know what's going to happen you
can't really control the outcome and
then when you just get beat the way they
did it's tough you know it's adversity
but uh the Lions been here before
they're gonna keep contining to fight
through adversity and keep bouncing
back um I would say golf gol obviously
didn't play his best game but the
football he's been playing he's been
playing very good football and I'm not
going to take that away from him him
because he had one bad week it's Any
Given Sunday NFL you're playing against
the best guys in the league so let's not
get this misconception that golf is
trash and things that other people like
to say no golf is very good he's playing
good football he just had an off night
he had an off day uh the Ravens were
just more prepared they out schemed the
uh Detroit Lions and that's what you
would expect out of a great team like
the Ravens who's trying to make a push
for championship football so uh
congratulations to the Ravens that was a
huge win um always big to see that uh
another quarterback that I want to talk
about right now is Jordan love the
Broncos beat the Packers uh 19 to 17
everyone was like is the Broncos finally
going to get back in the win column
which congratulations congratulations to
the Broncos way to get back in the win
column uh way to win at home uh that was
a big win we and they want to bring up
Jordan Love stats we could bring it up
this is the first two games uh you know
where he was hooping and things like
that versus his last four games which
his first two games he had six
touchdowns zero interceptions last four
games he had four touchdowns some
interceptions are fans overreacting by
saying he isn't the answer yes fans are
always overreacting they always do this
and it tends to always happen people
fail to realize even myself you go
through weeks where you're not playing
your best and sometimes it deals with
confidence sometimes it deals with
things around let's be honest why
did Aaron Rogers leave the Packers
besides the whole GM controversy and
things like that it's because they
weren't building around Aaron Rogers
Aaron Rogers is the reason why you go to
NFC championship games he's the reason
why you go to super bowls he's a Super
Bowl champion and multiple MVPs right so
you get rid of Aaron roggers you still
didn't bring no one offensively yes
Christian Watson's good and he'll
continue to be good yes they have Romeo
dobs but which one of those guys are all
Pros okay not he has no all Pro
receivers not even a pro bowl receiver
yes those guys are Pro Bowl talented but
they have been injured and dealing with
things like that and they're still
growing from the rookie year but Jordan
love hasn't got the opportunity that
guys like Josh Allen had got when they
traded and got a franchise guy I would
love to see the Packers draft a guy in
the first round this year I believe it
or not they passed on Justin Jefferson
back when he was in his draft class and
drafted Jordan love and the Vikings
ended up getting Justin Jefferson so one
they make these opportunities to go get
a franchise receiver a guy that's going
to go out there and get open and things
like that then we can say we can look
past but give Jordan the same
opportunity you give these other guys
same way with Jaylen Herz Jaylen Herz
year one and year two we're not the same
once he got AJ Brown give him the
opportunity for his GM to say hey let me
be build around my guy let me go get us
a receiver or draft a receiver a guy
that we could build around and create
opportunities and openings from my
quarterback so I'm not panick on Jordan
love because you saw the glimpses you
saw what he was capable of now you know
when you got film people are able to
adjust people were able to game plan for
you things like that so give him an
opportunity the same way we give
everyone else on the other side the
Broncos defense only allowed two
touchdowns a big jump from where they
were I'm proud the Broncos the Broncos
defense has always been legitimate even
since last year with guys like PSU PS2
and the surprising thing is they traded
away guys like Randy Gregory uh cut
Frank Clark and they doing this at an
extremely high level so that's how much
you believe in our youth so I think the
Broncos will keep progressing with this
young talented group that they have and
continue to get better especially ones
they keep overcoming these
injuries continue
furthermore one of the most exciting
games uh Sunday was the Patriots went
over the bills and this is another point
two weeks ago they said the Patriots
were trash they weren't good cuz the
Cowboys beat them and you know
furthermore how that goes and we'll
continue to get into this this uh
because that's just how the media plays
it um shout out to Bill Bic 300 regular
season win um he joined h of Famers uh
and coaches around the league with
history most 300 wins congratulations
bill um you're still one of the greatest
um you and Tom have did something that
no one's ever seen before in the
National Football League so kudos to you
guys but now we get to my guy M Jones
who I said was you know everyone said
should they move on should they go to
the Young quarterback that and I said
give ma time um and this is the reason
why you take a guy like M Jones and you
say let me be patient you know what I'm
saying that's how you build your
confidence you know no one had the
Patriot beating the bills at all okay
and this is what's special about it Matt
Jones the past two weeks he played us
and he paid the Saints and he didn't
have the greatest performances so he
went against the bills and this is a
game they had to win you know and this a
game the bills had to win and they had
an opportunity to fold but M Jones
stepped up built confidence in his team
and led them down to the game-winning
drive to win it what does that say about
M Jones that his confidence won't be
defeated that shows that he has grit
that just shows he has determination
that shows that he has all the tangibles
to potentially be a franchise guy you
just have to do it consistently the
great ones do it consistently I hope
Matt continues to do it consistently
keep building his confidence but I hope
this gives him the step that he needs to
keep doing it
consistently um the bills are now for
three and a lot of people were tending
to blame it on Josh Allen um some weeks
he looked like an MVP and some weeks he
seems a struggle I always say that when
Josh Allen is on he's on like there he's
Unstoppable Josh Allen that beat the
bills I mean the Josh Allen that beat
the Miami Dolphins is the Unstoppable
Josh Allen I think often sometimes you
play down to your uh competition and you
make simple mistakes that you think's
not going to hurt you or things that
might hurt you uh because you're overly
confident I think sometimes Josh play is
overly confident uh he truly believes in
his abilities he truly believes in
everything he does and my God should he
he has the most Talent quarterback top
five quarterback in the league and he
should and we shouldn't take away his
confidence I just think sometimes he has
to let know when to let the play go and
things like that but I'm not going to
get misr Josh still has a chance to turn
this around he still has a chance to
prove he Rong and keep being that top KB
class that we that we believe that he's
in and you know he just has to bounce
back you know he should the games that
he lost he shouldn't have lost so those
are paying ones you know you don't want
to lose those games and we see a banged
up bills defense which also is tough um
we obviously you see the difference with
matth Milano um Matt Milano is you know
a top three linebacker in the league and
I don't care what no one says and I
don't think he gets his flowers enough
um so we can't wait to see him back out
there uh and that that bills defense
needs him badly and you see it um since
he's been gone so uh that that's also
another Factor when you lose a captain a
guy like that and trust me we felt that
when we lost Trayvon Diggs who's the top
five Corner in my eyes in my opinion I
swear up and down to this day um it
hurts it hurts and you can't you can't
take that away another AFC East team
that lost on Sunday night was the
Dolphins AJ Brown continues wearing that
number 11 continue to dominate 10
receptions 137 yards and a touchdown I
mean we expect that out of AJ Brown um
definitely a top 10 receiver uh argue
what you want he could be you know top
five top seven however you want AJ
Brown's that dude I'm not taking that I
know he a dog um he know what it is uh
and it'll be exciting match up next week
but we're focusing on the Rams two and
Jaylen show respect after the game um uh
Tua Tua is always a very good
quarterback but you know the guy we
gonna talk about is you know Jaylen Herz
and I think Jaylen played a good game
he's still progressing he's still
continuing to getting better and I think
you know what you're going to get get
out of jayen you know he's going he's
going to make the pass he's going to uh
you know he's going to keep getting
better and he's you know making the
right decisions I think a lot of people
are getting down on him early in this
year because of the turnovers and costly
decisions he's made this year but I
think you know I think at this league he
has the same type of confidence that
Josh Allen has he believes my man is
better than your man and you know I
think Devonte Smith's better than a half
the corners in the league and he's
supposed to feel like I think AJ Brown
is better than half the more than half
the corners in the league and he should
feel that way so sometimes when you
throw it up and you say hey you just
gotta beat my guy and sometimes when
they lose that tends to happen and
there's nothing to be wrong about that
but Jaylen Herz is still playing good
ball they're still winning they're five-
one they have one of the best records in
the league and what can you take away
from them they're a good football team
they're a great football team um and
it's always good to see you know other
players doing well and uh making
inexcusable
football um a lot of people was now
questioning though the Dolphins schedule
the rest of the the reason why they're
having such a good start is because
their wins were the Chargers the
Patriots the Broncos the Giants and the
Panthers I'm not questioning that
because based off of football
knowledge uh the bills the bills you
know lost to the
Patriots the Patriots beat the bills
it's football it's about having your
best day out there on the field and we
are going to mention what is going on
and and and and we're not going to talk
about the fact that there were so many
Miss penalties so many flags that every
like if you gonna let one team play let
all teams play the Miami Dolphins had 10
penalties last night like 10 penalties
like come on man like and we and some of
them calls were very blatant very
noticeable and just bad calls okay but
call it both ways if you're not going to
let him play then then you know what I'm
saying like that's where I feel about it
and I and I I've been seeing this trend
around the league of more defensive
penalties and less offensive penalties
and I get that I think it's the M that
it's trending around the league where
these guys want to protect right who
brings the fans in right I know um a lot
of fans kind of love defense but a lot
of people love offense they love Justin
Jefferson they love Tyreek Hill they
love Patrick Mahomes and those are your
Idols I think a lot of kids grow up want
to be offensive guys so and you know who
do you want to watch on Sundays right
you want to watch Patrick Mahomes you
want to watch Josh Allen so I'm
thinking that the league is trying to
protect these guys in a normous manner
instead of letting playing football the
league is I think is going downwards in
a way of physicality things that people
love to see people that made people
excited to watch football you're missing
those big hits you're missing the the
action the thing that RS you up the
thing that makes you excited about the
football games and and that sucks uh
that these refs are taking away the game
I hate to see that Kem Jackson just got
suspended for making a good hit that's
how you put the fear into a man right
when people talk about football right
and and not talking about this new class
of football we're talking about football
where you could put strike fear into a
man you could come and put it down on
put it down on another man and say here
I'm here and you gotta deal with this
for 60 minutes right I just want that we
kind of miss that type of football the
type of football that people are missing
the fans are even calling out these are
bad calls I want to get back into that
yes the protection and safety of these
players are extremely important but at
the same time you can't focalize and
make this intent on one side of the ball
it has to go both ways um and you got to
protect defense too and I just don't
think it's the same way obviously with
these Miss calls um on defense so I I
just expect it to go both ways and
that's it bro um I know y'all were
asking me in the chat last week and uh
and with so many upsets this week I'm
gonna give you my top five teams in the
NFL right now
and this is this is no judgment and
we're g we're going to take the Cowboys
out because I don't want anyone to think
that this is any type of bias right and
you could argue this is with or without
the Cowboys I don't care because I know
how some of you fans and you know people
in the chat may get right uh my top five
I think number five I'm gonna go with
the Cleveland Browns I don't care what
people
say the Cleveland Browns are serious
even with their offensive struggles that
defense
has been so special and Miles Garrett
has been so special um and we'll get
into miles Garrett in a little bit but
that team has just been so special and
um I think they should be a undefeated
team right now um without a
doubt so number five and I think when
that offense starts to click when
Deshawn Watson starts to play like the
guy that we think he can be and I just
think it's the time off anybody that's
all football for two years we're
struggling the last football league you
know things change every year things
evolve um but it's been very impressed
what Cleveland has done and I've talked
about them since week one I'm very high
on Cleveland I think they're a great
team the guys that they added I mean
it's just
ridiculous um number five will be the
Cleveland
Browns I think number
four
is H number four we're going to go with
the Baltimore
Ravens the Baltimore
Ravens have a very good chance with
Odell Beckham Z flowers I
mean Lamar Jackson and they lost JK
Dobbins I think and their defense is
extremely good they got my guy over
there do always they got Marl humph I
mean Kyle Kyle Hamilton has looked
extremely good roquan Smith Patrick
Queen all playing great ball their
defense is good um and they've been
playing great ball they just can't beat
themselves if the Ravens beat themselves
they could be if they don't beat
themselves they could be a so much
better
team number
three my number three team in the
National Football
League this is where things get a little
shaky even though the record might not
show it
I might I'mma still have to go with
them the record doesn't show it but
I'mma still have to go with them and I'm
G still go with the Miami Dolphins I
just think they're so
explosive they're playing good ball on
defense but they still don't have Jaylen
Ramsey I think they had chances in that
Eagles game to be very
good um the game didn't go their way the
penalties really hurt them in crucial
moments uh
but their record may not show their
losses were to teams that are playoff
teams they don't have bad losses and the
way they lost they just they they beat
themselves but I think they could have
won that game a lot of things went
against them they're still
good
um number two
I still have to
go obviously the
49ers I think the 49ers no actually no
yeah we're going to go number two
49ers um the
49ers are just extremely good I mean you
look who they have and how they've been
performing I mean it's second and N
defense is loaded everything's loaded uh
it it's very special to see
um 49ers are a legitimate top three team
top two team maybe number one um if
that's how you feel about
it number one will have to be the
Philadelphia Eagles um regardless of
what people say no one has stopped the
tush push
yet um Javonte Smith could be a number
one receiver he could be uh AJ Brown's a
number one receiver
um man like it's just it's special to
see
um their offensive line Jason Kelce Hall
of Famer um Lane Johnson will be a Hall
of Famer
uh you know they're they're very special
um their DB core darus slay I mean crazy
Talent uh James Bradbery CL and I know
you saw the trade just got Kevin Bard um
very special to see I think the
Philadelphia and obviously I know I was
high on dalen Carter before he even got
the feeling I don't know how he fell to
them um very special without a doubt
very special group
um it it's very special to see what
they've done and they still have reic
they still have sweat um Jordan Davis
Fletch I mean this team is all around a
great team there I I don't believe they
have any weaknesses on their
team the one team that I wish I have put
in there and you could argue You could
argue them um any place is the Chiefs um
the Chiefs are the number one team um I
think they have the most experience the
Chiefs are definitely a top team and I
see that you guys are throwing the
Chiefs out there the Chiefs are very
good right they're very well coach I
think the Chiefs are the most coached
team in the National Football League but
the one thing and I think that's what
separated them in a Super Bowl their
experience how well coached they are
their
discipline but if you look at what these
teams have I think all these teams have
the potential to be better than the
Chiefs all those teams I named have way
more Talent than the Chiefs they have
more talent but talent doesn't always be
experience experience in knowledge is
the greatest gift you can ever have I
think the for the if the Eagles
had the chief's experience and knowledge
of the game they would have won a Super
Bowl but Philly I mean the Chiefs won
the Super Bowl because of Patrick
Mahomes mysterious his knowledge
everything he brings to the game he's a
leader but they don't have the same type
of talent that these other teams have
and that's the only reason why yes you
have Patrick Mahomes you have Travis
Kelsey very special to
see um um but um I think PCO has been
playing great um as their running back
this year but who else in that offense
do you truly fear right who do you fear
like when you play against the Eagles
you fear that Jaylen Herz is gonna run
you fear that AJ Brown's a deep dead you
fear Devon Smith you fear Dallas G you
fear that o line I mean DeAndre Swift I
mean you you you have to respect I think
people come into the Chiefs and say I
know we have to respect Travis Kelce and
Patrick Mahomes and you make the game
plan them two will have to beat us and
Travis been able to do that their
defense plays great together they play
great together um they have Chris Jones
they have some young guys uh but I don't
think and they play extremely well
together but I don't think they're more
talented than these other
teams um and and that's just my top five
teams and those are my
reasonings um you can argue disagree um
but that that's just respect um and
things like
that uh the players that I told you I
talk about you know so much I mean I
have unbelievable amount of love and
respect for this guy I
think he's one of the greatest players
of Our Generation Um and because
Cleveland has been
so they haven't been great these past
couple years and they're just starting
to Peak and I'm happy people are taking
notice to him now and that's my guy
miles Garrett I mean he's my defensive
dog of the week I mean nine tackles two
sacks he blocked the
kick I mean is this why this guy just
box like I might have to train with this
guy this offseason like this is truly
phenomenal um I do believe he's a
defensive player the year front
runner I always will say that defensive
guys should be an
MVP conversations I hate that defensive
guys aren't in MVP conversations right
cuz where're championships really won
championships are really won on defense
I don't care how many points you put up
because you look at the Chiefs and you
look at the eagles they both put up 40
plus points but it matter who got the
last stop who created that turnover Nick
Bolton's turnover and score for the
touchdown changed that whole game
defense wins championships at the end of
the day I don't care who you play for
where at defense wins
championships I think that we need to
put more defensive guys and MVP
conversations and here's why you take
your top five quarterbacks
right they're very dependent and this is
why it it's good to outweigh right right
so if a if a wide receiver drops the
ball and it goes into a Defender s
people say oh it's not the receiver's
fault right it's the QB's fault right
and then a lot of people argue oh it's
not the quarterback's fault it's the
receiver's fault that shouldn't go
against the quarterback well what about
when you got a guy like Tyreek Hill you
could throw it to him five yards away
and still take it 80 yards was that the
quarterback or was that the receiver he
didn't throw that ball Tyreek Hill make
special plays like that and that will go
towards guess what the quarterback stats
that's a 80 yard play that Tyreek Hill
made that now has the quarterback saying
he threw 80 yards
I think you should change the scale of
How It's looked upon because Tyreek Hill
should be in an MV conversation the
things he's doing this year is just
mindblowing it it I don't think Tua
makes Tyreek hill we seeing this success
with Patrick Mahomes now we're seeing it
with Tua it's it's 100% Tyreek Hill he's
getting open he's always open he's a guy
that doesn't matter I know he's there
like you got to respect him right so
why is it that Tua gets more loved than
Tyreek like it's just things like that
where I don't base it just off
of you know I don't want to just base it
off well he's a quarterback he has to
make the throws yes but they're very
dependent on each other so you can't
make the excuse if the receiver drops
the ball and the defender gets his
interception what it blams the receiver
well you know if my quarterback doesn't
throw me a good ball every time can I
blame him why I didn't have a 100 yards
today or if I don't get my taret if I
don't get my looks or my receptions like
we just have to be completely fair and
honest and say scheme and they they're
both working together but it shouldn't
just always be quarterback same with
dline you you're very dependent on your
other Edge rushers you're very dependent
on your D tackles everyone has to do
their job for everything to click um
that's why I hate almost MVP award like
MVP
um it's very it's a it's a very tough
word to give out and the way we give it
out makes it even harder um most valued
player I believe like Patrick Mahomes
and guys like Aaron Rogers
and if you take away Patrick Mahomes on
the Chiefs I don't think they would be a
top five team and that's just period
what Patrick Mahomes they're top five
team they you know argue it the way
they're doing it um he's still doing it
without without uh Tyreek Hill right
that's what makes him valuable he won a
Super without Tyreek Hill right he's a
valuable player I don't think there's no
one like him the throws he make what
he's able to do on the field is truly
exceptional you
know Aaron Rogers he was doing it with
Devonte
Adams he was the most valuable player um
but you don't see guys like him doing it
all because then we make excuses oh he
doesn't have receivers oh he doesn't
have
this we have to be real with ourselves
people let's just be real about it um
but further on we'll talk about the
Bears won a battle against the Raiders
the battles is a backup quarterbacks uh
Tyson Bean getting his first start place
to Justin Fields um who was the most
impressive backup QB in week
seven um who it's tough I want to go
with Tyson because how how dominant of
the winner was but I definitely think
Tyrod Taylor has been playing
exceptional even last week um they
barely lost to the bills but it's been
very special to see what he's doing at
this point I I had to look at my team
and say do I play better with Tyrod if
I'm really trying to make a chance for
playoffs at the end of the year do I
have a better chance with Tyrod or do I
have a better chance with Daniel Jones
and you know I I don't take they're both
good players very good players
um
but he has less to work with than Dane
Jones have Andrew Thomas wasn't playing
a few other lineman wasn't playing yes
he does have saquan Barkley back but
he's been able to do
this with less than when Daniel Jones
was
playing very special to see um so I'mma
always go with a guy like Tyrod because
he's doing consistent I would love to
see what Tyson does again um before I
give him who's the best backup
but it it's going to be very funny to
see I want to hear what y'all think
about it uh Tyrod or Danon Jones I mean
it's very back and forth it's very
choosy but however you look at it it's
very it it's it's a tossup where do you
want to go with your season and how you
do it I saw the stat that Travis Kelce
plays better when Taylor Swift's assist
uh and attendance I'mma give you two
things right and Travis Kel is my boy um
without a one I think Travis Kel he's
been a 99 for like the past three years
best tight end in the league for like
the past three four years so it's
obviously not Taylor Swift but I'mma
tell yall one thing when there is a bad
girl and she's in attendance and she's
watching you there gives you an extra
boost of confidence now Travis he
already had that Mojo he already had
that Swagger and everything and I think
he's gonna do this regardless he' been
doing it last way before a a swift even
came in a picture but dog y'all know how
it is when you pull up to the gym and
your girls with you I'm I don't care
who's in front of me kawhai Leonard
could be in front of me I gotta give him
30 I have to give him 30 you know you
feel me it it's like a given it's like a
giv I don't care who it is
right H like without a doubt in my mind
if my girl pulls up to the men's league
with me I don't care who's in front of
me I gotta give him 30 I refuse to go in
that car on the way home and my girl is
talking about damn he dropped you off
today huh n that's not happening so you
know what Kel is doing I I know what's
going on it it was like he was already
doing it so now it it's like yeah I'm
I'm going to do it more now like it like
it's a Swagger it's a confidence when
that things happens y know how I go come
on now peep
um and obviously she was wearing a
friendship bracelet with 87 on it I
think my friendship bracelet would have
like 11 11 from cuz like I should be
like your gift from like God almost like
that's how like we're so far like I had
to get on my ball game like I have to
get on my ball game point B perod I'm I
got to give out my friendship
bracelet
um you feel me like I'll have 11 from
heaven like or 11 lion something I don't
know it has to be pretty cool and like
catchy at the same time not too much not
too much but y know y'all get the
point
um
so obviously y'all know we we'll get
into this I I heard you guys talk about
my nitty
Lions oh my God this hurts this
hurts man this hurts I did not want to
lose that game toio State I did not want
to give Malik hooker that leverage I
mean that's tough I I I can't believe we
lost to Ohio State but there's a couple
things I took away from that game right
Ohio State pen have some of the best
defenses in college football without a
doubt one of the best defensive games
I've seen a very long
time
um
but that hurts oh my God shirs I think
we could have won that
game
um this that that just I mean bro I and
they want to talk about my dog coach
Franklin
um man I think coach Franklin's a great
coach and he does it the right way and I
mean he's a true Father Figure in my
life um but when you're playing those
type of games it really comes like this
right it it comes out like this like it
that game could have went very back and
forth you would obviously we had
offensive struggles and things like that
but it could have got better like that
would and and that's kind of why like
sometimes like even last year I wish
allar played last year more because it
would give him that opportunity to be
ready for games like this um he didn't
know especially know what to expect I
think allar is gonna be so much better
down the stretch of the season after
getting a game like that under his belt
and it'll be great to see how he bounces
back against a team like Michigan but P
state has to keep getting better keep
recruiting I am bringing these type of
guys that Ohio State have in so we can
keep competing we could keep coming down
to wire and take this leap cuz I think
we're very close we're very close um pen
State's winning without half the uh D I
mean recruiting classes Ohio state has
had in the past four or five years
so it it's coming it's coming and I I'm
G keep believing and it's always we are
also I've been very high on Kaleb
Williams um but USC just lost her second
game in a row to Utah and a lot of
critics say
he doesn't perform well against top
opponents and I just think that's BS
right you look at that uh Utah USC game
last year and uh in that big game uh
conference game I believe the Pack 12
championship and he played very well his
defense can't get a stop like people fa
like and that's why I keep saying a
quarterback is not the most valuable
player because it doesn't matter doesn't
matter how many points you put up and
how well you play if your defense can
not get stops if they cannot create
turnovers create opportunities field
position all those
things it very hurt very well hurt your
success you hear people on the line
saying he should just get ready for the
NFL I never agree and and before people
say anything yes I opted out um the
season before even started because they
canceled our season BR it back said
we're playing like six or seven
games whatever just a non natural
football season yes I opted
out um and it still haunts me to this
day and I know the experience I know the
feeling um there's things I wanted to
accomplish still left in my college
career but their season is not over
right when you when you check out when
you start something you finish it I hate
this generation
of well I made it so I don't have to do
this
anymore I
and I'm and this is when I get a little
spiritual and emotional because people
always do this right what's meant for
you what God has planned for you no one
can stop it what's meant for you is
meant for you right whether it's good
things bad things if God wants it to
happen for you it's going to happen for
you right and what God puts you through
he'll walk you through so what you start
you finish regardless of circumstances
that teaches you character it keep you
you ground it stand it it keeps on a
base that you stand on right I I would
hate to see Caleb Williams just stop
playing because he's a special talent
he's exciting to watch he's so good and
it's not like he's coming in at a
Patrick Mahomes level and he's just like
I'mma dominate like Patrick Mahomes
automatically a top three quarterback
yes he's gonna be a good quarterback but
you don't know how he's going to
transition you don't know anything yet
he's just a
prospect people I think people
are taking our granted of today like
tomorrow's not promised things are not
promised right you don't know what could
happen to Caleb Williams on or off the
field no one
knows but you have to understand that
what's meant for you is meant for you
like don't get caught up looking into
the future too much stay under like stay
under your feet right like stay what's
in front of you not like just stay
what's in front of you like stay what's
under you like keep going I do not think
he should just quit on his teammates on
his team bad show if you're if it's your
last bowl game and I know um there's
been some freaky accidents and obviously
if you're not playing for a national
championship and it's just some Co I
mean it's not a New York six game and
it's just some Outback Bowl you're
playing in I get it that game has
nothing to do with your career but
fighting now you have a chance to pick
your team up and continue the season and
show them why you are who you are show
Scouts why you are who you are you get
to show the fans why you are who you are
don't forget what you're doing it for at
the end of the day we are nothing
without the fans we are nothing without
god um and we're nothing without our
families don't ever forget that and and
this goes to all you know all college
kids
never forget your purpose right you're
we're here to inspire the generation the
generation after us we don't want to
create bad habits and bad Trends that's
just that that's just not who we are um
and that's more I have to say about I
would I would hate to see him just leave
uh College yes he's special um but he
can be even more special don't give up
on your dreams don't give up on your
team um this early in the season because
I mean we we would hate this seat I mean
we all would uh we know how special he
is
so um I would love to see him stay in
college but
furthermore looking ahead we got the
Rams coming off uh this
week um last year I had two sack three
so tackles the for f against the Rams
ended the game um always special Rams
games always fun um and it's always a
good chance for me to see the greatest
football player of my generation Don
play I'm super excited with him
hopefully I can swap jerseys with him
he's been my idol for so long um I love
to see him play I mean and obviously
y'all know I'm high on Cooper cup and uh
NOA so it's gonna be super excited to
play against them always a fun match up
Stafford's my is a guy too uh it's gonna
be a very fun match up um I think you
know NOA and Cooper cup are obviously a
top six wide receiver Duo um maybe even
higher top five maybe
um if I'm really thinking about who are
they who they
are um so max Stafford ranks obviously
Matt Stafford is a Super Bowl champ he's
obviously a top 15 uh top 10 quarterback
for sure without a doubt um very special
talent um and and that's what it is we
got to go out there win this week and
just worry about each team this week not
looking ahead and just staying under our
ground and obviously when I want to come
back next Monday talking about our win
over the ram so very exciting uh I can't
wait to see you guys next week and let's
just take some chats final questions
from the chat um before we get out of
here lots of chats about Tyrod Tyrod
Taylor um who will present more of a
challenge when Facing the Giants for you
Tyrod or Daniel Jones obviously people
like people forget how athletic Daniel
Jones is a guy who can extend plays get
outside the pocket and things like that
I think Daniel Jones always faces that
threat of that athletic guy that guy who
can extend plays he just do don't do it
at the same level as the other guys um
but he could continue to get better
let's not give up on him yet he hasn't
given us a true reason to give up on him
yet big trade DRFT today I talked about
earlier Kevin Byron bring to the Eagles
defense I think you get a ball Hunter
right you get a guy who's gonna get
after the ball create turnovers for you
a guy's gonna come down here Not Afraid
Al guy obviously all pro pro bowl guy uh
with veteran leadership I mean you
adding all these vets into your backend
uh truly special and I think he can make
more plays than Terrell Edmond obviously
berer is at the end of his career so
giving up a fifth and a sixth is kind of
tricky uh especially saying the type of
talent that a lot of teams been getting
late in these rounds right the type of
picks undrafted guy seventh round guys
like perie uh and y'all know way more
Fifth and six phenomenal players that go
on these rounds um so you don't know
about the two studs that these guys that
the Titans could get at out of those uh
two picks um look at woen he was a fifth
round pick you just don't know uh what
you're going to get out of these guys um
so I I believe it's it's a very I
wouldn't say the Eagles maybe especially
because the Titans probably are in tank
mode um they're trying to rebuild
obviously letting go of lean and um uh
and guys like that and obviously trading
AJ Brown and they might move him from
Ryan tanah Hill so they need draft
Capital um they thought about Rel in
Kevin B last year so getting trade value
getting a young player out of it is
really good and uh that's what you want
um from from Team like the Titans you
want to get trade value um they wanted
to get his money off of them so
obviously it's a good trade for both
teams uh how do I feel about Nolan Smith
get called baby Micah uh we're in a
generation of where people want to label
people people want to call me the young
LT the youngness but I think everyone
special you get a chance to you know I I
and I hate this opportunity you get
labeled so much in life right with
identities you get labeled with things
like that instead of just letting people
be special in their own way there's
things that Nolan does very well that I
don't do well there's things that I do
very well that Nolan probably doesn't do
very well I don't know his game um
fluently and things like that but he's a
great talent he's a first round pick but
let Nolan build his own identity don't
put him under the same lenses as other
players or me at the same lens as other
players we do that too much um like the
comparison is the thief of Joy let Nolan
enjoy his rookie year don't put these
expectations on people and all these
things that they don't need just let
them stay in a moment let them live let
them breathe let them build the identity
of who they want to be I created this
identity of a li This ferocious Lon the
hungry Lon like that was me I created
that like y'all gave me a chance to do
that no one knew who I would become just
like y' don't know who no become let him
create his identity let him create his
mode and let him play his best football
and that's why I'm praying for him
because Nolan's always been like a
little brother to me I mean through I I
try to get Nolan to Penn State I
recruited him uh I knew the type of
talent he was so I'm always very excited
uh for him
obviously and that's that um how has uh
who's your who's my MVP right
now uh I think the MVP race is very uh
debatable I don't think there's a clear
standout for MVP right now I give you
guys like miles Garrett I give you guys
like Tyreek Hill I mean Patrick Mahomes
is playing pretty well but it's not like
outlandish uh you know Jared G was
playing pretty well Tua um but obviously
they're having a little bit of early
struggles uh with both two losses so I
don't think there's a clear cut for MVP
right now I think everything's up for
discussion um and you know last question
is how has Mike McCarthy changed the
offense in the past few weeks they give
CD lamb more opportunities uh I think he
has seven receptions but I do do think
if you look at a brown he had 10
receptions I think CD is a 10 reception
10 Target guy 12 targets 13 targets I
think he's that especially he has a
chance to be that type of guy he just
needs some opportunity so I love that
fact that Mike had him going in that
direction he's still building with him
and still learning him um and things
like that so uh I love that um and last
question is would you ever want to be on
Cowboys be on hard KN or the distraction
um it's life I don't think anything is a
distraction some people may send my
podcast as a distraction some things
they say anything could be distraction
but at the end day it's you right you
have to know what your limits are you
have to know what your capabilities are
um and you know I always live by this
quote a d a man without dream shall not
perish y know how that go uh so y'all
just know what it is I don't think
anything's a distraction you let things
become a distraction like women you let
women become a distraction for you and
that's the thing that defeats you um if
you let you want to hang out all night
and not put nothing into your craft then
you let that distract you but I don't
think nothing is a distraction
distractions uh you allow distractions
to come into your life you allow things
to affect your life so always remember
never let anything affect you if it's
not helping you it's hurting you at the
end of the day and you don't want to
always stay in the same place but I
appreciate y'all I love y'all thank you
for tuning in to the edge it's always
special to be on here with y'all I can't
wait for next week hopefully we bring
back the win and you already know how
about them Cowboys that's a
rap
ah